la Competencia por la palma de oro
comenzó en cannes con dos películas
cargadas de misterio
[Música]
el maestro japonés irocasu Correa
inauguró el certamen de Canes con su
noveno largometraje Monster un Thriller
sobre los lazos entre una madre su hijo
y un profesor de su escuela
[Música]
Monster cuenta la vida de Minato un niño
de 10 años que comenzó a tener
reacciones extrañas en casa y en el
colegio su madre cree que uno de sus
profesores lo acosa la situación se
torna cada vez más compleja a medida que
el director ofrece detalles sobre la
naturaleza de Minato
[Aplausos]
[Música]
regresa por séptima vez a Lafayette con
este largometraje delicado con el que
compite por la palma de oro galardón que
ya ganó en 2018
el Jurado de cannes también vio la
primera cinta de una mujer directora de
las siete que concurre en este año se
trata del ojo el retorno de la francesa
el retorno fue filmada en la isla
francesa de córcega una familia
adinerada contrata a Kevin ya para
cuidar de sus hijos que di Ya regresa
con sus hijas a esta Isla cargada de
recuerdos dolorosos que dejó 15 años
atrás para sus hijas en cambio córcega
termina siendo un espacio de exploración
de sí mismas y de aventuras inéditas
luego tú es un drama salpicado de
críticas sobre el racismo ordinario y el
machismo reinante en ciertas capas de la
sociedad de córcega La Isla natal de la
directora de esta cinta